the EU is getting increasingly fed up
with Hungary its refusal to take a share
of migrants and refugees and a whole
raft of new regulations and laws my
guests here in Budapest is Zoltan Kovach
the Prime Minister's international
spokesman how long is his government
going to keep playing the bad boy in
Brussels
[Music]
zoltán Kovich welcome to conflict zone
thank you you're escalating rounds with
the EU and other bodies you seem
determined to take this to a major rift
why we've used two words here escalate
have used rift yes which I don't think
are appropriate here because we see
tendencies the decision-making
procedures in the life of the European
and we don't like we name that that's
been our politics policymaking for the
past seven years there are major bones
of content yes but the only way in our
belief that's our experience to sort out
through your problems is to name that
them and that is talk about them in a
frank manner in a way that can show that
at the end of the discussion if you like
a debate a fierce debate at times the
solution is there
it sounds very reasonable the way you're
discussing it but actually it's not
getting any better is it and you
yourself have said the fight is just at
the beginning the point of the debate is
sure about it there are issues and
topics in which we are going to be
unrelenting so you're prepared for it
may imagine if we have to fight it we
are going to go for it
one lesson we've learned for the past
seven years not necessary in in the
field or in by the topic of illegal
migration which is in the focus for the
past two three years economic matters
our own constitution it was worth taking
the fight because at the end of the day
turned out that we were right and we
don't like to be vindicated that's not
very wise if you are a politician or if
you run a country still that's a lesson
we have learned for the past seven years
the EU Commission has launched
infringement proceedings against Hungary
treatment of migrants refugees they
don't like your March 2017 Asylum law
restrictions on civil society
organisations legal reforms the
dominance of as they put it of
pro-government media these these are
serious issues on them No
we've seen so many topics so many
charges rather against Hungary for the
past seven years that again this is
nothing new so we go for them because
you don't take them seriously we did I
mean how can how can you take it more
serious than you to go for a legal
debate because at the end of the day
it's going to be sorted out legally you
went to the European Court of Justice
yes and they told you that they turned
down a question on whether it was
possible legally to make a decision like
that back in 2015 in face of decisions
about mandatory quotas yes in face of
two previous decisions on behalf of the
heads of states which clearly said no to
that now we face a problem here we
acknowledge the decision because
apparently illegally it was possible to
do so but immediately we face a very
serious political and the yet again
legal problem and acknowledge the
decision that's right your foreign
minister is on record as saying politics
has raped European law and raped
European values this decision
practically openly legitimizes the power
of the EU above the member states right
the EU and then setting aside that
inflammatory language what kind of EU
did you think you belong to well that we
face a serious political issue which
eventually becomes a legal issue and
that is how decision is done how
decisions are made in the European if
you knew that this is nothing new
well you knew that the EU member states
have no legal right to resist those
orders that's a real problem because
that again goes against the most
important word idea philosophy if you
like within the European Union that is
consensus if it's possible to give side
up to this members are required to
accept the judgment of the EU highest if
it is possible to go around even legally
rightly go around political consensus in
the European Union that doesn't make
sense does it and this happened back in
2015 inflation of EU law takes
precedence over domestic law in EU new
EU law is part of domestic law yeah you
have said you have to involve Union
located into your now if you wanted to
you know in the league of the way we all
know that EU law is a particular law as
it is being called it's not
international law it is as if it's right
and lawful it is incorporated into the
Member States legal system and that's
where we face a problem because for the
past seven years even more we face a
tendency and that is the stealth mode of
decision-making and the the formulation
and understanding of legal possibilities
in the European Union's decision making
process that is tending to overwrite
what is in the treaty but that's nothing
new I mean the other states of
experience that you didn't read the
small print did you when you join the EU
if it's nothing new for you it's
probably not for us it is because you
know there are limits there are red
lines we've drawn now we we suddenly
bumped into some serious problems and
that is our sovereignty yeah
who shall decide listen to the accident
that's right about Bres it should be a
lesson actually to Brussels bureaucracy
because it's it's not a cause it's an
outcome of problems regarding the
relationship of Brussels visibly London
but you went to the court to see if they
would overturn the ruling the mandatory
quotas they didn't so you accepted the
jurisdiction of the port yes I do that
and the court turned you down and now
you don't accept the result and we have
accepted you have we have acknowledged
the result you do not accept it we have
exchanged you behave you have
acknowledged that legally it was
possible to make a temporary a decision
on temporary measurement which we
believe again politically is not right
because that goes against the consensus
on a higher political level we still
believe that the highest political
decision-making body of the European
Union is the council but you my point my
point is you are not going to accept
those quotas are you we are not going to
accept the quota that despite the ruling
of the court you're bad losers then you
went to the court turned you down you're
a bad loser a bad loser would be who
sacrifices lots of things in Wayne but
we are sacrificing lots of things for a
reason and that is that's a sovereignty
issue even in a temporary decision we
are not accepting any composite decision
whom shall we live together in a country
we have never given up that an element
of our sovereignty and we're never going
to give it give that up and we whatever
it takes however far you have to push we
are going to use all political and legal
means actually to go against that that's
right
in March last year your Prime Minister
spoke condescendingly of flocks of
obsessed human rights defenders feeling
the overwhelming urge to reprimand us
and make allegations against us
yeah that's been the case for the past
couple of years that's right you you
join a club you sign up to various
commitments they're going to review your
progress that's that's the point of
joining the club why complain about it
now I'm trying to every time he comes on
them and everybody comes on the period
about doing to make this discussion into
some something reasonable it's our
vision of how Human Rights how the soft
elements of cooperation in the European
Union rule of law constitutional issues
are going based on principle and if you
don't like being held to account no no
no that's not the case the thing is that
the obsessed human rights defenders you
don't we want to we want to avoid you
want to avoid we want to avoid that
something an interpretation is taking
over the right sense of the word we have
agreed to and that's what is happening
the wider point about this is that you
don't feel that the Europe you join it
is a valid Europe anymore you set your
government now apparently sees itself as
protector of European values your prime
minister said twenty-seven years ago
here in Central Europe we believe that
Europe was our future today we feel that
we are the future so why do such as your
what you've suggested here this from a
man who boasted in 2014 or what I mean
breaking with the dogmas and ideologies
that have been adopted your question
suggests it's something which is
completely untrue we are not breaking
away from the European values and the
perception we had we stick to it and
that's the difference others are trying
to make it something different we have
agreed to you believe that you
a viewer we believe that that's quite a
tall order for one consciously yeah sure
but hunger is not standing alone I mean
if you take a look at for the past
especially two years so there are the
bad boys in the European Union you can
name that but let's let's talk serious
the Central European countries
eventually more than ten years after
their accession to the European Union
has come to their full fledged
perception of how they believe the
opinion should be working and I believe
this is something new there were some
European powers the Western member
states have to cope with them that is
Central European countries for for an
obvious reason that is historical
sociological economic reasons a legacy
we carry here have a say and different
say about how we think about the
European Union and you should better
listen listen to it it's not against
Europe it's a different slightly
different vision I mean the West is
turning down what you stand for you're a
liberal democracy in April even the
center-right grouping in the European
Parliament the EPP which includes your
party Fidesz warned you that it would
not accept any basic freedoms being
restricted or the rule of law being that
nobody's risk anything well they're not
buying your explanations fine we've
we've been through that for the past
couple of years and saying the economy
we were able to prove that we have to
hang on in line with European
regulations as a matter of fact sticking
better or more to the regulatory lines
or outlines that have been there than
others we are able to refurbish our
economy so there are lessons Western
Europe should if not learn at least take
a look because they took a look and they
don't like it it made this year the
Parliament condemned what it called
serious deterioration of the rule of
democracy so this is the name of the
game if it's about cooperation and
discussion at the end of the day you
have to reach consensus it's impossible
that's a Western European country is the
biggest state group of states enforces
something on others what they don't like
so that's not going to work that's that
if you ask about the future
a member of a club and the club has
rules and you're not accepting the rules
but the rules should be based on
consensus and a well based on majority
actually again consensus here is very
important for you you trumpet you
European music is telling you we're not
buying political consensus goes beyond
simple majority giver hofstadt phoned
the Belgian Prime Minister he's a great
friend of Hungary yes that's right
you said you signed up to the values of
the Union you have violated every single
one of them my question is how hopeful
mr. Ferriero SEPTA's is a great friend
of Hungary I'm being ironic here
he's been accusing us he's been throwing
us various things which have nothing to
do with reality but the thing is again
he's not alone in Europe alone in his
criticisms you see he's not but he
belongs to one particular cell you the
human rights or own NGOs the so-called
liberal mindset obviously doesn't like
what happens here in Hungary because we
go against their Dogma which is trying
to ensure that all achievements in the
European Union are being called liberal
that's what we deny coming back to your
liberal part you know there's very nice
sentence on behalf of the Prime Minister
which took us a couple of years to four
minutes very shortly but it's very nice
and this is a liberalism is when it's
not the Liberals who win the elections
and I believe this is what we talk about
here political differences a different
mindset is not supposed to override what
what are the real nature of European
decision-making and have the future here
and that is everything is based on
consensus and consensus is more than
simple majority why bother with the EU
if you're determined to break with its
dogma and ideologies as you put it wipe
other is it just the money
the 5.6 billion you get you get every
year is that money that's another
favorite point which is being brought up
if you take a look at how hunger is
cooperating with European institutions
and the European integration you would
be amazed because Hungary with campaigns
like let's halt Brussels next Russell's
in those issues I would rather say that
95% of those issues actually we have
consensus on and we work together
hunger is fully cooperating as a
menacing word finally in six billion
euros a year when you're running
campaigns directly against the
organization that gives you this money
you bring in here another topic which
has nothing to do with human rights and
the soft elements of cooperation in the
opinion the cohesion funds the support
Hungary and other European countries
mostly Central and Eastern European but
also southern European countries
received from the budget are not a gift
as a matter of fact they go back to the
very foundations of the European Union
and they tend to close or rather that
that goal that task is to close the gap
between the development differences in
the European Union we have opened up our
markets in a disadvantaged position for
the Western European you've opened up
your market you're staging what your
Prime Minister called a revolution
against the Alliance of the bureaucrats
of Brussels the liberal media and the
insatiable finance yes if it's also
rotten in Brussels and the finances are
so insatiable why keep on taking their
money have you have you ever been
involved in running a state even say a
town or a larger block everybody you
know that going against bureaucracy is a
legitimate goal baracus it tends to you
paint Brussels as rotten yes because in
many in many respects what they stay
with it you put three axes you put a
question which have never never been
raised by the Hungarian government if
you take a look at the government's
positions behavior the Hungarian
populations support for the European
idea values it's unquestionable so it's
a false argument it's a false narrative
that is being used against us we are not
going to play that game when I drag but
Chancellor Merkel has already suggested
that you may have financial penalties to
cope with that the eight ATM machine is
gonna be switched off hasn't she she's
already said anyone who rejects this
solidarity she means the Solidarity with
the migrants must accept that this will
not be without consequences including
for negotiations over futures financial
support yet again you write for that
you're trying to suggest here
something which is simply not true again
well it's coming you what she said - no
but what is coming from the Western
European countries what is coming from
the European budget to Hungary and
countries like it's not a gift it is to
ensure that equal access to the markets
competitiveness and other issues can be
achieved and for that for that reason as
a matter of fact the cohesion fund
system that is the money coming here and
mostly going back to Western Europe is a
mutually beneficial construction now
take a look at mr. Ettinger's words at
some point maybe a year ago he was very
clear about the benefit the beneficial
nature of the cohesion when you put that
money that money is going back to the
Western European party who seem to water
head for the exit but a man called salt
buyer probably didn't pronounce his name
correctly he said in July on the local
TV station here if the EU continues
along its current path then we have to
leave the Union leave this whole
scolding pigsty as he put it we need to
get the hell out we have to close our
borders and let the rest of them rot mr.
Baier is not a member of the government
of your party again if you're trying to
put up here a completely in sleeting and
false narrative and you won't accept
that's not that was quote I don't know
but you won't accept that there are
legitimate claims legitimate issues on
which we have to talk differently
especially in the light of what happened
with the European Union for the past
10-15 years then you are seriously wrong
we can when we named problems when we go
for issues which are not with the main
stream in European public opinion
especially the liberal public opinion
only broad political opinion this we
like that fight because we believe
that's that's a territory where the
fight should be done
you like a fight also you know I can
fight also about Christian values thank
you
you can you claim to be upholding
Christian values but you cannot deny the
very foundations of European culture do
you but you ignore the Pope's call to
exhibit those same Christian values and
open your doors to migrants don't you
well you feed your family
you were civilities you also have to
know that the religious commands and
politics sometimes are in conflict
because your first responsibility when
it's about taking care of those who are
in need
it goes for your own people that sounds
good but at the same time you know he is
a leader of hundreds yet again when we
talk about religious leader hundreds of
millions of people and your estate in
Central Europe but you think you know
better about religious values and what
Christianity Christian values are than
either in extraordinary position to be
in isn't it we don't talk about religion
proper here we talk about those
foundations on which Europe itself the
continent and the European Union is
based is on what basis do you lay claim
to being the protectors of Christian
values in Europe because apparently for
you especially for the past couple of
years Western Europe is tending to
forget what those values mean
and who you to judge in the judging we
are trying to portray Jim we are just
trying to portray what is happening and
this you know if you don't measure your
religious credentials if you don't name
a problem if you don't name that we are
shifting away from our own values and
giving up your own values doesn't mean
anything good actually for the future of
the European continent especially for
the European Union if you take a look at
the predecessors the founding fathers if
you like of European politicians they
firmly believed that Europe should be
based on Christianity if not religious
proper religious terms but certainly
culturally and if you read the way shift
away from that is going to cause very
serious problems look this is Luke
around the globe nobody's nobody's
playing that game does it disconnect you
claiming to protect Christian values at
the same time your authorities are
accused of illegal action including
denying entry to arresting summarily
rejecting and returning refugees using
disproportionate force on migrants and
refugees as well as reportedly
assaulting journalists and yet there you
are standing up claiming as I see we do
have here a serious linguistic
problem as well because you stick to the
word refugees and we stick to the
reality that this is not a refugee these
are migrants asylum seekers who are part
of a larger inter continent and mass
migration wave and we stand here
unprepared our old tools and methods are
not working and as a matter of fact we
are defenseless in face of what is
happening so first inherit defenses in
the face of 1,200 people that the EU
wants defense that's in the face of 2
million who came in the past two years
miss coverage one of the other big bones
of contention between Hungary and the EU
involves the Central European University
which has been founded by the Hungarian
born philanthropist George Soros it's
operated here for the last 25 years
you're even a graduate of it Jose that's
right got a PhD in history your Prime
Minister's called the University of
fraud and accused it of cheating did you
go to a university that cheats well ever
attended a university which has provided
high value educational support for many
Hungarians and many central Europeans
but we are talking about now for the
past almost year is not about that it's
about regulations but you've just
changed which to which Central European
University and 27 others we're not
coming up so when we change regulations
this is a rule of law that's what you
claim that the Hungary should be there
can be no exceptions but the real issue
is not the regulations is that the real
issue is that it was founded by George
Soros against whom your Prime Minister
has a personal vendetta doesn't he this
is this is a man who's talked about the
Soros plan indeed this is a very
interest an action plan that describes
exactly how disobedient non immigrant
Central European countries should be
transformed into immigrant countries and
in these destroyers has got under your
Prime Minister's skin indeed this is a
very interesting discussion because your
questions and accusations seem to be
reflecting reality which which is not
which is not the case mr. Shores named
himself as a political actor you
europe-wide but no so domestically in
in the previous in in a number of
previous interviews as a matter of fact
going back to 2015 they claimed to
become a political actor in this country
and if you wanted to become but he
hasn't got a democratic mandate but it's
not it's not about technicalities the
university it's about him reason you're
cracking down on the Central European
University is because it's him you
seriously believe that it's a
technicality that you need and
democratic amended to become a political
actor but your so your Minister of human
capacities let the cat out of the bag
Zoltan Balog he said you know the
existence of a strong autonomous and
internationally recognized university is
in Hungary's interests but it's not in
our interest to have players in the
background who conspiring against the
democratically elected government so
it's all about Soros isn't it that's
what it's all about so it's not about
the university or its regulations where
or its laws but an instance about him
when an institutional network or
elements of it are being used for
political purposes without him
democratic mandate we face a serious
problem here mr. Schurr has never been
given a democratic mandate many of those
who work in in those frameworks and
networks actually his running his money
is running have never been given a
democratic mandate to represent what
they represent as a matter of fact they
do not simply represent what they do
they go for it they try to push this
through the idea that he's trying to
push you to accept migrants yes this is
a man who wrote the EU cannot coerce
member states to accept refugees they do
not want all refugees to go where they
are not wanted yes he supports your
opinion he's not trying to curse you to
become anything at all as well you know
or didn't you read that article mr. mr.
Schurz has written many things as a
matter of fact in most of his writings
it's a completely different picture what
you see emerging and that is going back
to 2015 and that particular writing or
lecture is still available September 27
last year you know he back in 2015
September he has suggested at the peak
of the migration crisis completely
different things as a matter of fact he
has taken action talking to
leaders of the European Union using his
influence through the framework of the
Schorsch
Network also the European Union's
institutional framework to make his
ideas happen on the ground is very
serious very briefly because we're
running out of time you're gonna let
this university function if they come up
to the expectations yes of course
so you're digging in your heels on that
look again you expect Hungary work as a
rule of law if there are rules everybody
should come up to them and if other
universities including American
universities are able to come up then
it's a question of willingness rather
than capability total coverage could
have UN conflict so I thank you very
much
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]